and get two months free.
RESOLUTION.
SOME SWEARING OFF DESERTS I
AM.
GYM.
IT'S ODD HOW EMBARRASSING
2017 NEWS COVERAGE ACTUALLY
WAS.
IT WAS ABOUT A YEAR AGO THAT
THE "THE WASHINGTON POST"
WAS REPORTING, YOU WILL
REMEMBER, THAT RUSSIA HAD
BREECHESD
BREACHESD
BREACHEDD
BREACHED THE AMERICAN
ELECTRICAL GRID.
PANIC ENSUED.
THAT STORY WAS FALSE.
COUNTLESS CLAIMS REPREET
PETEED THAT THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT HACKED OUR
ELECTION.
THAT SUGGESTED THAT PUTIN
RIGGED IT OR ALTERED VOTE
TOTALS SOMEHOW THERE WAS
NEVER ANY EVIDENCE OF THAT
AND STILL ISN'T.
THEY ARE STILL SAYING IT.
HOW ABOUT THAT STORY HOW
FIKE FLYNN WAS GOING TO
TESTIFY TRUMP ORDERED LIMB
TO MAKE CONTACT WITH RUSSIA
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
REMEMBER THAT ONE?
ABC RAN IT AND RETRACTED IT
BUT NOT BECAUSE CAUSING BIG
SHORT-TERM LOSSES IN THE
STOCK MARKET.
OOPS.
THAT VERY SAME WEEK CNN MADE
UP A STORY ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP JR. AND WIKILEAKS.
REMEMBER THAT ONE?
WRONG AGAIN BUT THEY KEPT
GOING.
WE COULD KEEP GOING ON AND
ON AND ON.
DISHONEST AND CORRUPTS MEDIA
AWARDS OF THE YEAR ON MONDAY
AT 5:00.
SUBJECTS WILL COVER
DISHONESTY AND BAD REPORTING
IN THE VARIOUS CATEGORIES
FROM THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA.
STAY TUNED.
HE DOESN'T LIKE THE MEDIA.
DOES THAT GIVE REPORTERS
LICENSE TO BE SLOPPY AND
DISHONEST?
JOE CONCHA WRITES ABOUT THE
PRESS FOR THE HILL.
WE CAN GO THROUGH ALL THE
EXAMPLES OF THE PRESS
GETTING IT WRONG OR PUTTING
A THUMB ON THE SCALE.
I WANT TO TAKE THREE STEPS
BACK BECAUSE IT'S A NEW YEAR
AND ASK WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
IT SEEMS LIKE NEWS OUTLETS
ARE DEVALUING THEIR OWN
CURRENCY, WHICH IS
CREDIBILITY IN PURSUIT OF
TRUMP WANT IT'S THEY ARE
STILL DOING IT WHY?
LIKE "THE WASHINGTON POST"
AND "NEW YORK TIMES."
MOST READ YEARS EVER DIGITAL
SUBSCRIPTIONS UP, CNN AND
NBC MOST WATCHED YEARS FOR
THEM EVER.
GRANTED CNN STILL IN THIRD
PLACE, NBC STILL IN SECOND.
FOX NEWS IN FIRST.
IT'S BEEN VERY GOOD FOR
BUSINESS.
I ALSO THINK THAT IF YOU
ABANDON ALL NEUTRALITY,
TUCKER, THAT YOU ACTUALLY
GET A GOLD STAR OR POSSIBLY
PROMOTION OR AN AWARD.
LET ME GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE.
JORGE RAMOS IS AN ADVOCATE
WHO PLAYS ANCHOR ON TV.
HE SAID NEUTRALITY IS NOT AN
OPTION WHEN COVERING DONALD
THOSE WHO STAY SILENT ON
TRUMP.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE SOMEBODY
LEADING RESISTANCE.
AND IS HE GIVEN THE BIGGEST,
MOST PRESTIGE JUST AWARD IN
ANYMORE WHEN COVERING A
SITTING PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: JUDGMENT DAY IS
COMING.
THAT SUGGESTS A SPIRITUAL
ELEMENT TO THIS.
I WILL GIVE YOU ANOTHER
SERMON BY THE WAY.
BOB WOODWARD SAID ON CNN ON
SUNDAY.
THIS SUMS IT UP PERFECTLY.
IN LOTS OF REPORTING,
PARTICULARLY ON TELEVISION,
COMMENTARY THERE IS A
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS SMUGNESS
AND PEOPLE KIND OF
RIDICULING THE PRESIDENT.
WHEN WE REPORTED ONYX SON IT
WAS OBVIOUSLY A VERY
DIFFERENT ERA.
THE TONE WAS WHAT ARE THE
FACTS?
BOB WOODWARD GETS IT.
THEY PURSUED FACTS WITHOUT
ACTUALLY RIDICULING AND
THAT'S THE WAY WE SHOULD BE
GOING BEEN B. OUR BUSINESS
NOW.
IN 2018, TUCKER, THAT AIN'T
GOING TO CHANGE.
>> Tucker: IT SEEMS LIKE
AND, LOOK, I WILL STIPULATE
WHAT IS OBVIOUS WHICH IS THE
PRESIDENT GODS THE PRESS.
HE DOESN'T LIKE THEM.
HE IS ALWAYS TWEETING ABOUT
THEM.
I WONDER WHY NOBODY IN THE
PRESS CORPS HAS DECIDED I'M
NOT GOING TO RISE TO THE
BAIT.
AND I'M GOING TO PLAY IT AS
STRAIGHT AS I POSSIBLY CAN
AND LET MY STORIES SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES.
THEY SEEM PERSONALLY
OF THE MESS THEY TAKE IT
PERSONALLY.
MY WIFE IS ER DOCTOR.
SHE HAS COME PEOPLE COME
INTO THE EMERGENCY ROOM ALL
THE TIME LOTS ARE DRUG
SEEKERS FAKING ILLNESSES TO
GET A PRESCRIPTION.
WHEN THEY DON'T GET WHAT
THEY WANT THEY PERSONALLY
START TO ATTACK HER
VERBALLY.
SHE PUTS HER HEAD DOWN.
SHE IGNORES ALL THE
CRITICISM AND SHE DOES HER
JOB.
THEY SHOULD IGNORE WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS SAYING IN TERMS
OF FAKE NEWS AND THE TWEETS
THAT COME OUT EVERY DAY
BECAUSE HE KNOWS IT'S A
POLITICAL PLAY BECAUSE HIS
BASE THINKS THE MEDIA IS THE
OPPOSITION PARTY.
THEY NEED TO DO THAT.  BUT,
INSTEAD, WHAT THEY END UP
TOO LONG IS THEY TAKE
UNNAMED SOURCED INFORMATION
THAT'S WEAPONIZED FROM
PEOPLE THAT ARE PURPOSEFULLY
PUSHING FALSE NARRATIVES AND
THEY RUN WITH IT BECAUSE
THEY FEEL THAT'S AMMUNITION
AND THEY DON'T CARE IF THEY
DETECTIVE IT WRONG BECAUSE
THERE IS NEVER ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE MOST
PART WHETHER THEY DO GET IT
WRONG.
>> Tucker: VERY QUICK, 10
SECONDS.
THEY TOLD US FOR A YEAR THAT
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN COLLUDED
WITH THE PUTIN GOVERNMENT TO
STEAL THE ELECTIONS.
IF IT TURNS OUT NOT TO BE
TRUE, WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE
THEM?
>> IT LEAVES THEM WITH HALF
OF THEIR AUDIENCE BELIEVING
THAT IT STILL IS TRUE AND
NARRATIVE TO PUSH AS LONG AS
IT'S NEGATIVE TOWARDS THE
ADMINISTRATION.